a company owned by one of the world's
richest people was given the green light
to build nearly 25 miles of underground
tunnels self-driving cars will be taking
people to the stops on and off the strip
much quicker Joshua piguero reports on
the increased locations and costs
associated with catching a ride
there are 18 stops on this proposed
project one of them is Resorts World
tourists we spoke to say they'd use it
but they didn't agree on whether it's a
good investment I think I would use it I
think it would be I don't know if it'd
be cost effective building tunnels
there's probably more cost effective
things to do I think it's just like AI I
don't think it's going to stop I think
once we let this technology loose it's
just going to keep growing and making
our lives better the Clark County zoning
commission is allowing Elon musk's
company to build the equivalent of a
marathon underground 18 stops all on the
25 mile route are being proposed in and
around the strip they include the Virgin
Resort the Westin Las Vegas Boulevard
and Elvis Presley the Las Vegas sign and
Town Square the boring company estimates
a trip from the Las Vegas Convention
Center to Allegiant Stadium would take
only four minutes and cost around six
dollars but commissioner Marilyn
Kirkpatrick expressed her concerns
that's one on the record commitment to
consider the employees that have to act
access this very area as well that there
will be an opportunity for them to
use the system as a park and ride system
the boring company has already been
approved for six underground stops that
connect areas of the convention center I
know I can stand here and commit to you
that they are looking at opportunities
in the future to expand out into the
valley into the north the South West and
East of the strip the boring company
also proposes that you can get to
downtown Las Vegas in three minutes for
five dollars reporting on the Strip
Joshua peguero eight news now